- There are a lot of people
who are 45 to 60 years old
who just are complaining about millennials
and they're not actually asking
how they are getting back in the mix
by becoming a beginner again.
- And are being held accountable
for parenting and
creating the millennials.
- You got your perspective.
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
Hey everybody.
It's Gary Vaynerchuk,
and I have a really special guest here.
An entrepreneur that I've
known for a very long time
and I got an email.
I got a lot of emails,
I got an email either from him or his crew
and they're like, "Chips got
some stuff to talk about."
I'm like, "yes!"
So here we are.
- [Chip] Thank you.
On MLK day, we're filming
and recording this.
Chip Conley is in the building.
Chip, why don't you tell everybody
who's listening a little
bit about yourself?
And then, very frankly,
some of the things you want to talk about
and then we'll riff.
- Yeah.
So, great to be here.
Congratulations on the digs here
- [Gary] Thanks. Thank you.
It's pretty nice.
I'm staying at the Equinox
Hotel right near by,
- [Gary] Which is very nice.
- Which is very, very nice.
Getting a massage tonight.
(chuckles)
Um, so,
yeah.
I started the second largest
boutique hotel company
in the U.S. when I was
26, called Joie de Vivre,
based in San Francisco.
All 52 of the hotels
were all in California.
Sold it and then seven years--
- How did the first one start?
'Cause I know this audience.
When they hear that hyperbole,
everyone's like "how?"
- I was two years out of
Stanford Business School,
in fact I was hanging out
with my friend Seth Godin yesterday,
here in New York,
and who I went to business school with.
So, I started the first one
by buying a pay-by-the-hour motel.
Not because I was frequenting it--
(both men laugh)
- [Gary] Which would've been fun!
- Because it was cheap and--
- How'd you have any capital?
- I raised about 1.1 million dollars.
So, I was 26.
I had gone to Stanford Business School,
gone to Stanford undergrad.
Had a lot of friends who had money
I was not from a money family.
- What year was this?
- It was 1986, '86, '87.
- You know it's funny.
That's a little bit, like I don't have--
- [Chip] Before your time.
- Yes.
Enough before my time
that I don't have a good enough read
on how ridiculously hard
or ridiculously easy.
Even going to Stanford,
when I hear '86, '87,
and I hear 1.1,
like, I'm like oh,
that's a real accomplish-
You know now, kids--
- [Chip] I don't know
- Well, I'll say this.
Listen, raising capital is
it's own game in itself.
But, today, you don't
have to be that remarkable
to actually be able to
raise a million dollars
for a start-up idea
because of what's happened
in the last decade.
- [Chip] That's true.
- Paint this for me.
In 1986, '87, in the Stanford world,
like, was that incredibly difficult?
Was that two families
that had so much money?
Give me a little context
to make it practical.
- It was about 20 investors,
all putting about 50k each in.
So, it was like a syndication,
that's what we used to call it.
- Did people think it was crazy
to give a 26-year-old?
- It was crazy
because I was 26. And I
had no hotel experience.
- Again, now, the 22-year-old
getting a million bucks
seems common.
Then it seems to me like an enigma.
- It was wacky and it was a--
- Or was things happening
because it was Stanford,
and San Francisco.
- San Francisco was-
this was - San Francisco
was not what it is today, then.
Long story short is, it
was big people betting
on me, not on the business plan.
And not on the real estate because
it was a broken down motel in the
Tenderloin of San Francisco.
And it became- So, I raised the money.
Took me three and a half years to
get it to a place where it was
clearly a success story.
It became the rock n' roll hotel
in San Francisco.
So everybody from David Bowie to
Linda Ronstadt were staying there
as this funky motel and--
- How did you get the first "get"?
- The first "get"?
- Yeah, like the first
person that was cool,
that you got, because
that became the domino
to--
- In terms of the investors
- No,
- or in terms of the guests?
- Guests.
- It was all about the tour manager.
Everybody thought it
was all about going out
and marketing to the travel agents.
No, it was actually the
person who made the decision,
was the guy who's about
five years older than
the rest of the band, who wanted to make
sure they didn't do an overdose or that
a groupie wouldn't, like, hijack them.
- [Gary] Yes.
- And so we gave that- We
did a deal where we said,
"We have a massage
treatment room, you can get
a free massage if you
bring us ten room nights."
and so the tour managers
started talking to
each other, and next thing I knew,
all the tour managers and the bus
drivers- the bus drivers
liked us just because
we had free bus parking too.
So at the end of the day, you 'gotta
determine, like, what do you have that's
your benefit?
And we had a massage studio and
a parking lot.
- Uh-huh. No, I like that.
- And the tour manager bought it,
and the next thing I knew-
we basically for thirty-three
years now that hotel,
it's called The Phoenix.
Funky motel in the Tenderloin.
- And were you there every day?
- I was there every day in the early days.
Yeah, for sure.,
- [Gary] Yeah, yeah of course.
- And I was learning the business.
I didn't know anything about it.
- [Gary] Of course.
- I didn't go to Cornell Hotel School
or anything like that. So--
- Why'd you want to do it?
- I loved- I first of all had a lot of
people staying on my couch.
(both men laugh)
- So you know, little market research
was like, "why are you
all staying on my couch?
Why don't you stay at a hotel?"
And they kept saying, "the hotels in San
Francisco are either really expensive
or really boring."
- Who are these people?
- Friends, who are coming
to visit San Francisco.
So I--
- Where did you grow up?
- I grew up in L.A. Grew up in Long Beach.
I went to Snoop Dogg's high school.
So I'm from LBC- famous.
- I love it.
- Long Beach Poly High School,
was number one high school for--
- Might have been a slightly different
high school when you and
Snoop were there or same?
- [Chip] No, no.
- Yeah, I'm askin'.
Snoop was about ten years younger than me,
but he stayed at my hotels.
Which you need to know after Snoop
stays in your hotel
room, you definitely need
to fumigate a little bit.
- Yep.
- Just because there's a little bit
still a stench of the weed.
So yeah, when I was back there,
no- I heard they called
me "curious white boy".
I did basketball, uh, like you.
- [Gary] Nice.
- Last time I think I saw Gary
as we were playing.
We were at summit, at
sea, up on the top deck,
playing full court basketball while he
was in his sandals.
I'm surprised you didn't break a leg.
- [Gary] It's true, I'm super happy.
- No, but I had that company
for twenty-four years,
sold it.
It's now a high brand
and long story short is, I,
seven years ago, was asked by the
three founders of Airbnb to come help
them grow their company into a
global hospitality brand.
So, I've spent seven years as
Brian Chesky's mentor and I was the head
of global hospitality and strategy
for the company for four years full time.
And then for the last
three years, just been
like a strategic advisor to them.
- That's cool.
- And part of the reason I'm here
is because, while I was there, you know,
they call me "curious white boy"
when I was in high school.
They call me the "modern elder" at Airbnb,
and I did not like that.
But I was twice the age of the
average employee at Airbnb.
I started when I was fifty-two,
I'm fifty-nine now.
- For everybody who's listening,
my great run in kind of
the Silicon Valley investment world,
definitely was kind of like
'05-- to like '06 to like 2010,
and what's interesting about hearing this
story is that Chip absolutely like was,
in those circles with me
and there was just like--
there was a bunch--
there was probably like forty
to a hundred fifty people
that weren't hardcore attack.
Had come from different backgrounds,
but were kind of like in the mix
one way or the other.
It's really fun to hear that,
that's where you ended up
and how it makes so much fucking sense
because the value prop on context
and reps that you were able to
bring that exact company is like
the most logical shit I've ever heard.
- It was so funny because when I joined--
first of all for the first five months
we didn't tell anyone that I joined.
So, we didn't tell the press.
We wanted to see how
Brian and I got along.
- Where did you meet Brian originally?
- Brian just called me.
He just called me out of the blue.
One of the things I'll say about Brian,
a lot of people think it's the hubris
that makes a great CEO, its actually
the humility.
- Hundred percent.
- In Brian's case he
had the humility to say
"I don't know a bunch of
stuff, so I am gonna go out--
and when it comes to hospitality,
I'm gonna go talk to this guy who's in
San Francisco.
Who's created a boutique hotel company,
he's an entrepreneur."
- Who's in the mix with our community.
Which really mattered at the time.
- [Chip] That's true.
- It always does but I
remembered very vividly.
- All the people who looked at me like,
"what the hell are you doing?"
finally was announced five months later,
it was like why would you --
- Well that was your old world.
- My brethren in the hotel world
had no clue what Airbnb was.
And so, long story short is,
it led me to becoming this "modern elder".
And I'm what the hell's a "modern elder"?
The traditional elder of the past
was all about reverence.
You revered your elders,
but a modern elder is about relevance.
And so you better be as curious as you
are wise.
So at age fifty-two I was
joining a tech company
for the first time.
I didn't understand the lingo,
but I had to learn.
And so what I had to do was be humble.
I had to be open to like, saying, "I don't
know what you fucking mean by saying
you're gonna ship a feature.
Explain that to me."
And so, I was the person who could come in
and make the bridges
and create the bridges
to the travel industry.
And I was Brian's mentor and helping him
to look at leadership
from a CEO's perspective.
But the problem in our society today,
and I think you talked a little bit
about this in the past,
is we're gonna live
longer, power is moving younger, and the
world is changing faster.
And there's a collection
of people in middle life
who feel irrelevant and bewildered.
- And have a ton to give.
- [Chip] They do.
- But to your point, and
I'm sure my team smiled
'cause it's a word I talk a lot about,
it's gonna take humility on both fronts.
- For sure, there are a lot of people
who are 45 to 60 years old
who just are complaining about
millennials and they're not
actually asking how they are getting back
in the mix by becoming a beginner again.
- And aren't being held accountable
for parenting and
creating the millennials.
(Chip laughs)
It's my favorite dynamic right now.
- [Chip] That too.
- Literally, I go to these dinners
or whatever and like
they're shitting on it,
and I'm like, "you're the parent.
You're the one that
created this entitlement."
You know because everybody had to
have a fucking trophy.
- Here's the thing I've learned.
I had something to teach Brian,
Brian had something to teach me.
- Thousand percent.
- And I had a hundred mentors over my
seven years now at Airbnb,
and each one of those hundred mentees--
I'm sorry, I had a hundred--
well interesting I said that.
I said I had a hundred mentors.
Well, I did.
I was gonna say a hundred mentees,
but mutual mentorship is the future
of learning in development
in the companies.
- I am such a fucking buyer of what
you are putting down right now.
I think we're about to go
through the golden era.
We're going through it at Vayner.
- [Chip] Yeah.
- Uh, I hired a new chief creative officer
and I told him, "one of the things I want
to do in 2020 is hire retired copywriters,
literally from the Mad Men era,
there's so much to bring to the table.
Nobody looks at them as a viable option.
I like literally can't wait to hire them.
A. A lot of them are so financially sound
on the East Coast here anyway like
they'll be thrilled to
work for minimum wage,
let alone something more than that.
And they'll be fun!
And the kids are gonna learn.
- After the tech industry, I think the
advertising industry probably has the
highest level of age-ism out there.
- I think that's right,
I'm such a foreigner to it
and now that I'm in it, I'm like, "yes".
I don't understand how you're not
as creative at fifty-two as you were
at thirty-nine, it's silly.
- There's a lot of opportunity here and so
what that's led to, and I
wrote this book called--
- Well it's funny, I
apologize-- we talked about
football before we went on
and I think a lot about coaching.
Look at the two coaches that are going to
be in the Super Bowl.
One's a vet coach--
- [Chip] Finally.
- And one's a young coach.
Well and he's been to the Super Bowl.
- [Chip] He's been but he's never won.
- No and hopefully it's
not finally for you
'cause you're a 9er's fan
and you don't want him to
win this one. (Chip laughs)
But then you have Shanahan,
who's a young buck, right?
- [Chip] Yeah.
- And in the NFL you've seen that.
You've seen a guy go with
Carroll and Belichick
and Reid over here,
who are the old girl guard.
And then you've got this whole
McVay, Shanahan young guard
and I really actually
believe there's a lot there.
- [Chip] Yeah.
- I actually think, you know, in politics,
I think a lot about the founding fathers,
of how young they are and how old
a lot of our politicians are,
and I think that's great!
But I think you need the
mix of two and the friction
and I think you- I'm very
much buying what you're
putting down and I think knowing you
enough from the outside world and the
serendipitous ways we've
ran into each other,
I'm excited that you are
clearly thinking about
being one of the champions
in this conversation
because I think its a good one.
- Well it's why I wrote this book--
- It's also gonna bring
a lot of happiness.
- [Chip] It is.
- You're about to help a ton of
forty-five to seventy-two year olds.
- You know what's
interesting, is people's-
you're forty-four?
- [Gary] Four.
- Okay, couple of thoughts on forty-four.
Forty-four, frankly, you're right there.
Your life has been different
than the average person
but you know, the lowest
point of happiness
across cultures, is about
the age of forty-seven.
- [Gary] Interesting.
- What happens is this
"U" curve of happiness.
People are happy and they get less--
- James, how old are you?
- [James] Fifty-two.
- Understood. And you were shaking your
head on that forty-seven.
- [James] We worked out some data, for a
happiness curve.
- And you found it to be
in that range? Interesting.
- So it's fascinating.
- [Gary] Keep going.
- Long story short is-
- Can't wait! Three years away.
- You're fine, you're fine.
- [Gary] I'll be okay.
- Listen, if you- how
long are you gonna live,
first of all?
- I think one eleven for me.
- One eleven? Wow. So if you live til'
one eleven, you're probably not even into
the second quarter of your adult life yet.
- You're preachin'.
I'm not even sure I left the dugout yet.
- When I recently was hanging out with
my dad, scuba diving in Indonesia and--
- Cas'.
- Yeah, cas'.
- [Gary] Cas'.
- And I went on one of those online sites,
put through my data in there and they said
that I was gonna live til' ninety-eight.
- [Gary] That's cool.
- And I did the math.
And this was two years ago,
this' a year and a half ago,
two years ago, and I was
fifty-seven at the time.
The truth is, is if I do
live til ninety-eight,
at age fifty-seven, I
was not even at half time
of my adult life-
- Of your adult life. Understood.
- So you're probably-
if you live to a hundred
eleven- you might be going
into the second quarter.
- Listen, my relationship
with time and the
ability to be hyper but have a great
patience graph--
- [Chip] Yeah.
- Is something that I beat the drum of
very heavily 'cause it will help people
because so many people are anxious
'cause they think they have
to figure it out at thirty.
- Well they see these people
like Brian Chesky, and--
- But there's like seven of them.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I keep reminding them.
There's fucking forty-two of these people.
- This is why a lot of
people feel entitled.
- No shit!
- Or they feel a sense of
like, "if he can do it,
I can do it."
So I wrote a book, called "Wisdom at Work:
The Making of a Modern Elder"
based upon my Airbnb experience.
- When did it come out?
- It came out last year.
Came out- actually, came
out the end of last year.
I'm sorry, end of 2018.
- And do you feel that,
that might- you know,
it's funny, I really wanna
ask you this question.
It came out in 2018, late 2018.
- [Chip] Yeah.
- Are you excited because
if you're analyzing
that conversation, you're a hair early,
like in the macro and that it's
starting to build momentum?
Just curious on your own personal take.
- Yes, the answer is, this
probably came out about
six months before the
things started to hit.
- And I would argue, and
tell me what you think,
'cause it's a conversation
on passion about,
it's still wildly not being talked about.
- No, no. Age-ism or
even just the subject of
age diversity has been
proven that actually age
is the number one form
of diversity on teams.
So better than race
diversity, I mean we need
all kinds of diversity,
lets start with that.
But age is a more
effective form of diversity
than race, gender,
sexual orientation, etc.
For a lot of reasons.
Primarily because our brain is different,
as we're older versus younger.
So that lead me to reading-
creating something called
the Modern Elder Academy.
So it's the world's first
middle life wisdom school.
It's been open now for two years.
It's in Baja, so I get to live
an hour North of Cabo San
Lucas on the Pacific Coast.
- There's also great wine there.
- Great wine in--
- The other side, yep.
- That's exactly, the Guadalupe Valley.
So um yeah, so we've had
seven hundred fifty--
- This sounds fuckin' remarkable.
- Alums.
Average age fifty-three.
From twenty-two countries.
- Are you teaching?
- I'm teaching. I just taught
last week with a guy named
Paul Hawken, famous environmentalist,
author, and entrepreneur.
Yeah, it's amazing.
- [Gary] Good for you.
- So it's a social
enterprise too, so we give
scholarships as well.
So we give about a million
and a half dollars a year.
- How much does it cost?
- It's like for a single it's
fifty-five hundred for a week.
Double occupancy is four
thousand for a week,
but that's all inclusive and that includes
everything, including a massage.
(Gary laughs)
Massage is the theme here, you know.
- Do some people look at
it as- I can understand it.
Very interesting.
How much is it again?
- So its four thousand
to fifty-five hundred,
but there's scholarships-
- For a week?
- For a whole week, three meals a day,
full on gourmet staff.
The kitchen staff.
The number one thing is--
- Do you feel like some
people who can afford
it or even if they can't
afford it but scholarships-
see it as a mix between
advancement and vacation?
- It's both. It's like
transformational travel--
- It makes sense, think about where it is.
You know why I'm stopping
and again I think you
guys saw on the setup,
lik literally if you know
anything about me, like the email, I saw
Chip's name and I said, "yes".
So I literally had no idea what the fuck
we were talking about.
- [Chip] Thank you.
- I'm so oblivious to
everything, like I didn't
even realize how long you run at Airbnb
and things of that nature.
But this is so hitting me, so perfectly.
I wanna stick here for a minute.
I think it's really clever because I think
what I really like about it is, is
like I don't like vacations.
- [Chip] Yeah.
- Like let me rephrase- I like vacations.
But like, I don't wanna scuba dive or like
rock climb, but this thing you just said,
I'm like, "oh that'd be cool".
And I'm pumped, like I'm in a great place
and not looking for like,
"oh fuck I don't know".
Like I'm in a great place and I'm like,
"maybe I should- I'm gonna trick Chip into
letting me teach".
So I'll just take it--
- Come co-lead with me for a week.
- We'll talk about it.
Honestly I'm super fascinated by this.
- [Chip] Yeah.
- More importantly,
I've like- not exhausted, but I've done
a very good job for my own self.
Judging my own self, over the last
thirty-six months, to really pounding
a certain conversation to a certain demo.
I'm wildly excited about
fifty-five to ninety.
- [Chip] Yeah.
- Like I really am.
- This is your modern elder period, truly.
- No, no I like it. Forget about me,
I want fuckers to realize
they are fifty-two
and their gonna live
for another thirty-eight
years minimumly-
- [Chip] Yes.
- And like what the fuck
are you wrapping it up?
- Yep, exactly.
- The fuck are we talking about?
- No, it's crazy.
- It's crazy. All the rules Chip,
are predicated and when
people live to forty,
all the rules!
- At age forty seven--
(Gary sighs)
- -was the longevity in the year 1900
and it was seventy-seven by the year 2000.
So we added thirty years of longevity in
one century.
But we also introduced
a whole new concept,
which is the mid-life crisis, in 1965,
and now it is fifty-five years later,
and we've done very little to address the
"mid-life crisis", so to speak.
- [Gary] I really like that.
- Mid-life suicide is up fifty percent
compared to the year 2000.
So long story short is,
I said I wanted to create
the world's first middle
life wisdom school
because the premise- there's a new word in
the academic world called "midolescents".
So adolescents,we know
what an adolescent is.
- [Gary] Yep.
- But that word is only a
hundred and fifteen years old.
So prior to the word adolescence being
in the lexicon a hundred
and fifteen years ago,
people at age thirteen, when
they hit puberty were an adult.
And you got married and you had kids
and you worked in the mines, etc.
- [Gary] Yep.
- And then adolescences became a clear,
newer life stage.
- I like where you're
going with this. I got it!
- The life stage between
childhood and adulthood.
So we have midolescents.
It's the stage between
adulthood and elderhood.
Elderhood is different than elderly,
elderhood is a relative term.
At Airbnb I learned the hard way.
I was a modern elder, because I
was twice the age of the
average employee there.
So I- I owned the word.
And I had to say, okay
but it's a modern elder
because they're as
curious as they are wise.
So, what kind of programs do we have for
people in midlife if
they wanna go press the
reset button on their life?
We don't have them.
And so, that's the bottom line.
- [Gary] That's cool.
- There's a study out of
Yale from a woman named
Becca Levy, that shows
that if you actually
help people move from a negative to
neutral perspective on aging to a
positive one, you actually add seven and
a half good years to their life.
- I believe that.
- And that's more time added than if you
actually have them stop smoking
or you have them actually
start working out.
So it's like a public health benefit.
- Listen, nobody's a bigger
buyer of perspective,
is actual life.
You find what you're looking for.
- It's all mindset.
- I believe in that shit, bro.
- [Chip] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's awesome, that's
really really neat.
So what, you wanna build
like fuckin' Harvard?
- No, no. More than anything
what I'd like to do,
I've been lucky enough to be on the board
of the Burning Man Project
for about ten years,
and I just stepped down.
I'd like to do what they did
or what the Esalenist who did in Big Sur
which is, be the first of its kind
and then basically create the category
and so, whether the category
is transformational festivals
with burning men or personal growth
with treat centers with Esalen,
we will create the category
of middle life wisdom schools
all over the world.
- [Gray] Yeah I like it a
lot, I'm a buyer. Very cool.
- [Chip] Come on down to Baja.
- I will,
- [Chip] Especially this time of the year
- I'm not against it, like
I really like I really,
I talk a lot about people
visiting retirement homes,
I talk a lot about 50 60 70,
I think people are just checking out
when the game is still on.
- [Chip] Yeah.
- It's because, specially if
you are fifty five right now,
you grew up in a house hold
where your grand parents
were dying around that age.
- [Chip] Yeah.
- You know like, people don't understand
how much advancement has happened--
- Well, plus, you also had a hierarchy,
I mean, back in the old days
you sort of paid your dues
and then you got to 55
and then you started to
go out on the golf course
and won't have to work hard
and then the recession of
10 years ago, 12 years ago
came along and you lost your job.
Actually, I think 1/4 of
the people that you asked,
age 50 or older lost their
job in the great recession
and they didn't find it again.
They lost it and they would
start working at Walmart.
So there's a lot of people
who fit this profile
and there's a lot of wisdom
because one of the things
that has been proven
is that your emotional
intelligence grows with age.
- You have context,
experience in fukin' matters.
- [Chip] So, that's my story.
- Very, very interesting.
- [Chip] It's great to see you.
- It's great to see you.
Let me ask you a couple
of different things.
You've said you had 750--
- [Chip] 750 alarms now from 22 packages.
- Give me a Anic Donald's story.
- Let me tell you that Anic Donald's story
that talks about the divers-
- [Gray] Please,
- Why we detrimated social enterprise.
There was an arbiter period
the first six months.
We had a 45 year old white
male retired investment banker
who was wealthy but didn't have purpose.
- [Gray] Right.
- And we had a 62 year old social worker,
African-American social worker female,
lots of purpose, no money.
We didn't set them up to
actually learn from each other
but they went for a walk on
the beach every single day
because our four-acre campus
is right on the beach.
And, what we've come to realize,
is that wisdom is not taught, it's shared.
And what you do is you create
a cohort of 18 to 20 people--
- Are you guys- do you have enough demand
that you guys can be thoughtful in the--
- Yeah, and that was very popular--
- Cause what, you know
I'm practical, right?
- Like we are on the cover of
South West Airlines magazine
January of last year, we're on the cover
of The New York Time's business section.
- Is this a for-profit business?
- No, it's a social enterprise.
I don't take a damn and
over 50% of our people
are on scholarship in the first year, so
could it be a for-profit
business absolutely?
Are there some big global
hospitality companies
watching us right now?
Yes, probably because--
- 'Cause you're an entrepreneur,
do you have hopes for it to be?
- Yeah, so here's the thing. So I--
- Which I think is awesome
by the way just to like,
I hate when you're like, not
allowed to like be into it.
- [Chip] No, I know.
This has every potential to
be a for-profit business.
- Do you personally want it to be?
I mean that.
- Yes, I would like to
see for-profit and social
and non-profit both,
- [Gray] Yeah, great
- Like, why not both
- And more importantly to your point,
other people feeding of the hypothesis
to do whatever they want with it.
- Yeah, I think part of the reason
these global hotel change are looking
at this as a couple of things.
Number one is that they look at Chip.
They say, okay 33 years ago,
one of the boutique hoteliers.
Seven years ago,
joined Airbnb whenever he
thought he was an idiot.
What's his next thing? And
his next thing seems to be
this middle life school wisdom thing.
- Right, and you have leverage of success
which is gonna make them
take it more seriously.
- [Chip] There's that, and there's also--
- Do you hate that ever?
- No.
- You know I asked you-
(Chip laughs)
let me tell you all right,
I don't know you well enough to ask this
but I'll tell you why.
- [Chip] Yeah.
- I so enjoy being underdog
and under estimated
that right now I'm getting to a funny part
where I have enough
wins and consistent wins
and I'm out there enough.
- [Chip] Yeah.
- Then now I feel like oh,
when I come up with new crazy shit,
too many people think it's gonna work
and I'm just kind of joined-
I'm having fun with you.
I was curious what you thought about that.
- Well, let me tel you--
- How much enjoyment
did you get out of like
your world thinking it's
crazy went to Airbnb
and then being right,
how much do you,
like where are you now
because I bet you the
majority people that know you
in your space think this
is now gonna be a success
'cause two 'W's in a row
gives you that cloud.
- There's no doubt about that
but you start talking to
people about their age,
(Chip laughs)
and they actually don't wanna hear it,
so there's an element
and I'm talking about like
the executives at these
you know Mary Ann Holton higher--
- Interesting, you're
poking up a sensitive spot.
- It's sort of like- okay
and frankly the CEOs of those companies
who I know pretty well
are not gonna get all worked up
because they've had their success.
- [Gray] That's right.
- But there's that middle level person
who doesn't know if they are gonna be able
to have their job a year from now,
who sort of says, "Uh! I don't know
what of middle life
wisdom school would be.
So, long story short is,
yes I appreciate the fact that my pedigree
has allowed me to get to a place
where people do keep an
eye of what I'm doing,
but when you do something weird
and created a middle life wisdom school,
it sounds a little weird.
- God that feels so fuckin' right to me.
- [Chip] Yeah, I know.
- It really does.
- [Chip] So, it's necessary
- Now I understand
why I got the email.
- We're gonna see a hundred of these
in the next 10 years so--
- I'm a buyer of that.
- That's my job, it's to go
out and be the pipe piper.
- I'm a huge buyer of that.
- [Chip] So-
- Good for you.
- [Chip] Yeah.
- Well, let me know how I can help
and we will talk about me coming to Baja.
- Thank you, love it.
- Where can everybody check it out
if they wanna do some homework
or what do they google?
- They could go to
http://www.modernelderacademy.org-
- [Gray] Http://www.modernelderacademy.org
- Or com, either one.
They can go to my website
http://www.chipconley.com
C-O-N-L-E-Y and--
- And the book is called?
- 'Wisdom At Work: The
making of a modern elder.'
- Chip thanks for being on.
- [Chip] Yeah, yeah.
- This was good bro.
- [Chip] It's great to see you
- I'm so glad you reached out
'cause I think this is
gonna hit this audience.
Guys, I hope you enjoyed that.
Please give us some feedback on social
so I can get the quality, the
data and like the enjoyment
or your thoughts on it.
I think if you're following this
you ain't know how much
I give a shit about this
so smart of Chipper
team to reach out to me
because this is the right
audience and more importantly,
I'm also slightly aware that
an enormous amount of
you are still younger
and have parents and loved once that
are probably not even
fuckin' thinking about this
so make sure they listen
to this podcast I think,
if we impact one of your
parents to get happy,
that's a narrow or wide positive of that.